[Aplausos]
[Música]
la economía estadounidense vuelve a
regir el reporte del departamento del
trabajo que confirmó que 900 43.000
empleos fueron creados en julio generó
optimismo en la bolsa de valores además
de un descenso en la tasa del desempleo
que actualmente es del 5.4 por ciento la
cifra reportada este viernes excedió las
proyecciones de economistas que
estimaban 860 mil nuevos trabajos en
julio el presidente joe biden celebró
lo que es indiscutible ahora es esto el
plan de bailén está funcionando el plan
de bailén está generando resultados y el
plan de bailén está haciendo avanzar al
país somos ahora la primera
administración en la historia en sumar
empleos cada mes en los primeros seis
meses en el cargo y la primera en la
historia en sumar más de cuatro millones
de trabajos en sus primeros seis meses
first sex más el mandatario volvió a
referirse a la que llama la pandemia de
los no vacunados cuyas sombras se
extiende sobre eeuu el país registra las
mayores cifras de contagio de los
últimos seis meses para varios analistas
el avance de contagios debido a la
variante delta resulta preocupante
creo que existe preocupación por la
variante de él está en el horizonte no
podemos solo ver este reporte y decir
que constituye un progreso sustancial
necesitamos ver qué pasará los próximos
meses
las industrias hotelera y gastronómica
están en gran parte detrás del auge de
empleos con la reapertura los
empleadores subieron los salarios para
atraer empleados y aunque el crecimiento
económico dependerá del control del
virus
bailén asegura que la variante delta no
logrará hacer un daño tan grande como el
visto en 2020 cuando se perdieron 22
millones de empleos entre marzo y abril